suicide is one of the leading causes of
death in our country and actually in the
world and yet it's largely preventable
it has been trending up in terms of our
national rate of suicide over the last
decade or so
it had trended down prior to that so
we're at a place now where we really
want to make a difference we want to use
the methods that we know can work to
lower the suicide rate and allow those
who are struggling to get the help that
they need
mental health problems play a
significant role for suicide risk in
fact if you had to pick out one of the
many risk factors that tend to come
together to create suicide mental health
problems could be called actually
necessary but not sufficient factor in
place in greater than 90% of cases of
suicide as shown in the research there
is a diagnosable mental health condition
at play whether or not it was diagnosed
or treated now many other factors then
lay on top of that to to rise up to
create an imminent risk for that sense
of desperation hopelessness but then
also the thought the planning and the
ability to act on those suicidal
impulses
it is really important to note that
white males in their middle age account
for about 70 percent of the death toll
from suicide each year and in fact over
the last decade the rate of suicide for
that part of our population went up the
most it went up almost 30% you can think
about things like they are just as prone
to mental health problems as any other
segment of society and yet they might be
some of the folks in our society who are
the least willing or able to seek help
because of social norms and frankly
because men don't seek care medical care
as as much as as frequently as women do
in general let alone when it comes to
mental health one other factor that's
really important to understand is that
for the baby boomer generation that
group as a cohort starting many decades
ago actually had already shown an
increased risk for mental health
problems in suicide addictions and other
other psychosocial problems
ten years ago within the
suicide-prevention world and which is a
you know pretty specialized world there
was there were very limited activities
going on on the grassroots level there
were some and it was largely families
who had lost a loved one to suicide in
our organization for example we went
from a few people banding together to
over 150,000 people walking speaking out
about their experience of even lived
experience of having lived through
suicidal thinking or attempts that level
of awareness raising and sort of
shedding of the stigma is a is one of
the signs of just the changing times and
the readiness the desire to make an
impact on suicide